[Music]  i believe this is the first reference am  i wrong about this of to charlie killing  rats women find him interactive because  he's half fly  there are so many memes from the show  that it's like almost his own internet  language he doesn't quite make it he he  has diary in his pants i'd like to do a  reveal of my ears would jail stay sharp  [Laughter]  why are all the new spider-man movies  about him being you know whatever  distance he is from from his home he has  no toilet paper so he's wiping his butt  with his own head shots  far from home like i can't get home i'm  not home now but call me later it's  meaningless  i just got actually emotionally  [Music]